hi everyone welcome back to another
workout session and guess who's here
with us it's marco so we'll be doing
kickboxing today so a lot of you have
enjoyed our last kickboxing session so
marco what will we be doing today so
today we are going to have a nice
self-defense workout that we are going
to have in a progression we are going to
learn from the basics and how we
complete the movement so we are going to
use some defensive movements for your
upper body and some defensive movements
for your lower body and we are going to
have as well some sweat we are going to
have a heat conditioning and we will
have a nice workout as a partner so if
you want you can do this with your best
friend with your partner whoever whoever
you want or you can do it as well by
yourself you can just be alternating the
movements and you will have a nice fun
yes so this workout will be very
interactive okay grab your partner if
you have a partner and let's
sweat together
[Music]
hi guys now we are going to start with
our warm-up and let me explain you what
we are going to do we will have a
workout 45 seconds in 15 seconds out so
we are going to have an alternating with
your partner so the first one we are
going to work out on your upper body we
are going to have a combination jab
cross and left hook and your partner
will be putting just to reach the
movements okay we are going to be
alternating and then we are going to
have two different exercises that we are
going to alternate
for the second round we are going to
continue with the progression and now we
are going to have some blocks and for
the last one we are going to sleep to
complete our defensive moves okay for
your kicks it's gonna be the same we're
going to block we're going to have a
nice counter and we're going to have
some fun in the end of the workout you
will see so let's get ready
warm up let's get warming up and let's
put your legs on move
let's get ready here
and we're going to do
a bit of jumping jacks in three
into let's go just move with your hands
let's put a heart rate up
from here we are going to use some
movements and we are going to start
doing some jab and cross while we keep
jacking okay three
two and let's go one on the right one on
the left
we're going to use this movement laid it
on
good job
keep it up keep it up
remember to keep your hands up all the
time and from here we are going to go
for some shuffles one leg forward one
leg back in three
into
let's go
let's play with your legs
conditioning
remember self defense is also running
you don't get in troubles okay
we're having here nice
shuffles
and let's get ready we want to warm up
with some speed feet let's get ready for
that three
two and spit
moving faster faster
keep it up keep it up keep it up
three two and just relax your arms relax
your legs and let's get ready
from here remember we're going to start
with a jab
cross and left hook that's going to be
our first combination
the second time we're going to do
a plank position and we're going to have
some high knees we will explain you how
to do it later on and then we are going
to have some push-ups and nice stops
okay let's get ready 20 seconds just
relax you ready joanna yes i am
first combination remember it's gonna be
a jab cross so i will throw the punches
jab
cross and joanna will be just having the
moves okay we are going to play a bit
around and jab cross and hook
this is going to be our first 45 seconds
let's get ready three
two and let's go jump cross left hook
and move keep your hands up jump cross
and hook
all the time
one two three punches keep moving
one two and three your partner will be
just following your moves
good job keep moving one two and three
we have 20 more seconds here
keep moving
one two three you can move forward
one two three you can get backward one
two three
remember this is just to have some fun
with your partner so you can keep
moving
everywhere you want okay
the nice
thing of this is that you can have a
nice workout workout here sorry i miss
one punch and now we have 15 seconds
recovery
time for joanna to practice his moves
her moves ready yes i am we have five
more seconds recover recovery
three
two and let's go jab cross and hook
now she's moving one two and three
i will keep my hands up all the time
joanna is throwing nice punches here
good job
[Applause]
good job
one two and three you can move backwards
one two three you can go forward one two
three good job keep moving
this is the combination that we are
going to have for the next progression
okay
that's why we need to lose find your
movements
one two and three one more time one two
three good job we have 10 seconds here
and from here we will have 15 seconds
recovery and we go for the
one two and three 15 seconds recovery
now what we're going to do we're going
to squat face your partner and we're
going to use only your right leg so i
will kick all the time joanna will vlog
all the time remember squat down and now
bring your leg up ready down and kick
down and kick good job
remember to keep your hand up
if you are blocking
make your knee up all the way to your
hip
if you are kicking try to twist so you
have a nice rotation on your hips all
the way here
good job
nice one good balance
first time
we're going to do all the kicks i will
be kicking all the time joanna will be
blocking for the second minute of this
we are going to switch
and joanna will start doing the kicks
that's it now you will feel it
on your leg as well but you are moving
your right three
two and shake it off good job
now i will be blocking remember for your
blocks bring your knee up to your elbow
for your kicks
joanna will show the nice kicks on the
right side
ready let's go three
two let's go down
and kick down
and kick good job
we're going to have here nice workout
also for lower body
good job
all the time
feel the contraction as well here on
your obliques
so we are going to do a nice crunch so
your protection as well works on your
core
bring your knee up
and you will have a nice crunch on your
core as well
bring it up
that's it look at this
nice kicks
10 seconds more
good job
three
two last one
good job now let's get for some
heat conditioning now joanna will be
doing a plank and i will be doing 10
high knees and i will jump over okay
let's get ready
three
two engage your core in your planking
and let's go with some speed here five
six seven eight nine ten
and jump one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten and jump
good job here as well you need to trust
on your partner you are not going to
step on your partner
big jump
and keep it up
then high knees
and big jump to the side good job
as one for me
and jump
and
recovery time good job
how was the plank yeah shaking but again
now my time for working in my core
joanna will be doing the
10 high knees and jump over ready my
best
don't step on me let's go
that was close
you will be trusting your partner after
this i told you
yes
maintain your core stable
your high knee is working on your
conditioning
it's well on your core
remember always inhale from your nose
and exhale from your mouth okay
arms are shaking already but we are good
ten seconds more
oh last one last one last one
three
two
and that's it
good job
let's go now
we have another round now we're going to
have
one push up and we're going to top
with your partner four times okay ready
going down for a push-up three
two and down and one
two
three and four push up down and one
two
three and four and down
one more time
good job
you have 30 more seconds
you will be coordinating with your
partner
to ensure that everybody
is having a nice workout but we are
still alive
good job we have 10 more seconds
almost there last one last four one
two
three
four good job
working on the upper body
let's work it a bit on your lower body
we're going to do five pulsing down
holding your squat and we're going to do
a nice high five okay ready
pulsing and three two one one two three
four five good job
two three four five jump
five done
yeah
five
up one two three four
five up
two three four five nice one
good job
we have 15 more seconds
good
don't lose your account don't use your
count
three four five jump one two three four
five jump last one
three four five and that's it
15 seconds recovery
and let's go for the last of this we're
going to get as we did in the warm-up
punch and jacks okay
so this is going to be
as many as we can do in three
into
let's go
maintain a reading here with your
partner as well
you can coordinate your punches you can
coordinate your moves
easy
inhale from your nose
exhale from your mouth
get your core
on your toes
you will feel the workout on your couch
now you will feel the workout on your
shoulders maintain your guard up
that's it
we have 10 more seconds
and now we're going to get ready
for the last
five seconds to go
three
two
and one let's have a break and we will
do a next round
[Music]
okay guys ready for the second round now
we are going to learn how to block the
punches so we're going to continue with
the same combination i will do a jab
joanna will block
cross she will lock and then
in my hook she will put the elbow up to
protect her face okay so now we are
learning how to block for the kicks now
we are going to use the same
one kick and one block but we're going
to use now our left side okay for your
exercises now we're going to do instead
of just a plank we're going to do top
shoulders while your partner will do the
high knees and jump okay
we're going to add some push-ups there i
will let you know when so let's get
ready for the second round in three
in two in one let's go with the jab with
a cross and hook good job move around
keep playing with your position maintain
your gut up and one two and three
punches good job protecting your face
all the time jeff cross and hook good
job
that's it the important thing here is
just protecting your face protecting
your body with your arms okay
one two and three good job move around
and one two three remember you can play
with the space here one step forward one
two and hook get back and get to your
position one two and three we have ten
more seconds let's go here one two three
keep moving and one two and three we
have the last one one two three and 15
seconds that we're going to have for the
preparation on the second round so now
joanna will punch i will be protecting
my face okay ready yes we have five more
seconds to go shake it off and let's get
ready for your
second minute of the workout let's go
jab cross and hook that's it one two and
three good job play with your space one
two and put your hand up
good job you are protecting your face
all the time
good you wanna throwing the punches i'm
blocking all the way
always protecting my face
good job
keep moving
that's it protect your face all the time
nice one we have 10 more seconds
keep moving
good job now you will know how to block
a punch when somebody is getting
straight to you
one two and block good job put your hand
up and 15 seconds recovery let's go now
on the left side i will be kicking on my
left joanna will be doing the block okay
remember nice squat
bring your elbow when you come up on the
block
the knee to the elbow ready and let's go
down and left good job one
and left
all the way here
so remember with your knee you are
bringing up to your elbow protecting all
the paths of my kick that is not gonna
reach your body so you are holding my
kick
with your block nice one
while we are working on the blocks on
the kicks we are also working in your
core working in your lower body
come down kick
down and kick
looking good we have 10 more seconds
get your car and get your car
that's it five more seconds
three
two
and last one good job
now my time to protect
from joanna's kick
we are going to go on the left side of
joanna and i will be making the block
okay ready yes i am three
two
and
let's go down
and one yes all the power here
good job
bring your knee up remember stable core
ring just your knee all the way up to
protect your body come down in your
squat working out there
but protecting with your knee up
remember
this is going to help you always
when somebody wants to attack
your lower body with your shin you can
protect
your body okay
all the way down
good job
ten seconds more
keep working on your squat
good job three
two
let's go for one more
and that's it 15 seconds recovery now
guess who's gonna make a plank joanna
will be planking with tapping shoulders
okay i will be doing
the high knees close the jump let's get
ready three
two and go
good job
jump over
and high knees
all the power here and a big jump
that's it
big jump quick jumps
don't step on your partner all good
there
you anna yes so far so good so far so
good let's go let's go this is the last
one for me three
two one more jump
that's it 15 seconds
my time to work out on my core good luck
with your cardio juana oh my gosh it's
gonna be high jump it is gonna be
we got this
you gotta trust me i'll i'll do i'll do
three two let's go i will be topping
shoulders
[Music]
keeping my knees high yeah
get your core if you are planking
engage your core if you are in your high
knees and make a nice
[Music]
jump have 15 more seconds
looking good so far
stable mountain you're breathing in
one more second
three
two and the last one good job oh well
done all good yes
now
we need to work out as well
in the strength of our upper body so now
it's time to do
double push up and your four taps okay
easy version you can go to your knees
yes so
i will do the
hard part joanna will do the version
whenever you need to keep working out so
we're gonna stop remember we have always
an option to don't stop you can go to
your knees
come down all the way one and two and
tap
tap tap
tap
one
two
remember when you are doing your
push-ups on your knees your hips will be
high your chest will be down okay
if you are doing the push-ups on your
toes try to come on the same
shoulders and butt at the same time okay
one two and last one
that's it
good job well done now let's go for your
five pulses
and we're going to have two jumps ready
uh also also a easy version is gonna be
to do a power squat go to your toes
ready
five four three two one and one
and two one two three
four five one
two one two three four five one
two good job
look at these jumps three four five one
two all the engagement with your hips
and one
two
five four three two one one
two five
four three two one up one
two last one five four three two one two
jumps one
and two good job
nice
okay feeling already warning on the legs
good now let's go for the final round
of this we're going to do shuffles
remember
one leg forward one leg back play with
your hands three
two let's go
shuffles all the time
inhale from your nose
exhale from your mouth
and your core stable
all the time engage
maintain your core tight
this movement
helps you when you run
play with the balance of your hands will
give you will give you some speed will
give you some balance for sure
ten more seconds
keep it up
three
two
and round two it's done awesome let's
have a break and we come for the round
number three
okay guys let's go for the final round
now we are going to learn how to slip
the punches so what we are going to do
same combination i will throw the punch
and joanna will sleep not blocking but
just moving around so jab and then cross
and then when i throw my hook you will
knock under okay this is gonna be the
first one second minute or second
combination we are going to counter so i
will go for a kick and then she will
kick me back okay now she will counter
we are going to have a nice push or
plank in this time while your partner is
jumping and then we are going to have
three push-ups and three jumpings okay
let's get ready for that last minute of
the workout let's get ready in three
in two
let's go
and one two and under good job move
around good job one two
under good place with a play with your
place one two under good job
when somebody's attacking you you can
just play with your hips play with your
position and
lift the punches good job one two all
the way
this underdog can also help you if
somebody wants to grab you from the neck
you can just
boom skip it out
one two down
we have 10 more seconds one two
roll it down
one two almost there give me one more
one two
and the last one jump cross and under
good job fifteen seconds
now my time to defend
so we start here
jab cross and on the dock
ready yes
let's go let's go
three
two and go one two one under yes one two
on the duck
good job
nice
play with your hips play with your neck
good job
hands up protecting your face
and move out remember always watch your
opponent
even when you are moving out keep
watching your opponent you know what is
going to be the next move for them from
them
good job keep playing around
good good good
one two on the last one last one one two
under and good job
fifteen seconds now i will start with my
kicks and joanna will will do the
counter okay
one kick and then i will block because
she will counter my kicks okay ready
alternating your legs in three into
let's go down
one and block
down one and block
good job
same thing
contracting your core all the time
you need to be faster on your reaction
step back
and get all ready with the counter
block counter immediately good job
good
one
look we have 10 more seconds
and
good job that was quick
that was tired on the legs i know i know
now we are going to start
joanna will kick i will counter okay
okay
so right leg
starting with your right okay three
two let's go down block and counter good
block and fast reaction
look at this yeah
i block react
look react good job
strong cake oops
i wouldn't
15 more seconds
cake
counter yeah
counter
almost there we have five more seconds
the last one
and block and protect good job
15 seconds now let's go
push your plank and i will beat the
jumps okay
let's get ready
remember on the ground engaging your
core
on your high knees make some speed let's
go
keep going keep going
all the power
in your jumps
eight nine ten
big jump
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten big jump
i have tens more seconds
keep it off
and last one
six seven eight nine ten and
that's it oh my gosh
have some fire or not yet as on fire
so now my turn
for the push-up planks
as low as you can
as fast as you can
while you are up ready let's go
[Music]
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
looking strong marco
still still still okay you're still okay
yes
we have 20 more seconds
final 15 seconds
look got this
all the power on the core
all the power on the cardio for your
partner
we have one more round
for your upper body for your lower body
now we go for three push-ups and three
jumps okay let's get ready remember your
option underneath three
two let's go
one
two
three and clap one two
three and four maintain your core stable
one
two
three
and one
two
three and four good job
remember maintaining your knees
on the ground
put your hips up
you go with your toes try to go always
at the same time with your butt and your
shoulders down
10 seconds more come on johanna one
two three last steps one two three and
give me some more push-ups
one two let's go okay
okay joanna owes me one push-up i know
i'll count it
let's get ready now five pulses three
jumps okay
ready yes three
two
let's go one two three four five and one
two
three
five four three two one and one
two
three
five four three two one and one
two
three
five four
three two one and one
two
three we have still 15 seconds keep it
up
four five one
two
three
ten seconds more two more jumps and five
one
two
three last five pulses three four five
one
two
three good job
nice
guess what we have the last minute of
the workout so now we go for one minute
it's a workout for your partner with
your partner we're going to go in the
speed feed
and we're going to alternate the call
out on one movement okay ready let's go
jump
whoo okay
purpose
going hard with the morphe
push up
speed feet spitfit
jumping jacks two times
ah
jump a squad
[Music]
okay
last one last one
stop
good job
well done catch your breath
drink some water if you need or just
stay here with me we are going to cool
down we deserve a nice cool down for
this workout so catch your breath in
inhale
and exhale one more time inhale
[Music]
and exhale and the last one inhale
get your breath your hands up
stretch your arms feel the stretching on
your arms three
two and one move to the right
five
four
three
two and one from the center let's move
to the left and five
four
three
two
one get back to the center and now bring
your hands forward your hips back
stretch your body here five
four
three
two and one get your hands on your back
stretch it up put your chin down five
four
three
two and one tap the floor with your
hands spread your hamstrings stretch
your arms
five
four
three
two and one split a bit your legs and go
with your hands to your ankles all the
way here five
four
three
two and one left hand to your right
ankle
both hands in the right three
two and one walk your hands all the way
to the left side and three
two and one walk your hands to the
middle and now let's walk the hands all
the way back to the line of your heels
spontaneity there five
four
three
two and one walk your hands forward and
now walk your feet together
catch your toes and come down in a deep
squat open your arms
open your knees with your elbows
chest up five
four
three
two and one bring your hips up
stretch your hamstrings three
two and one catch some air from down
inhale
and exhale and now catch your right arm
on the front pull it with your left feel
the stretch on your arm three
two
and one bring your hand up and pull your
elbow down
three
two
and one we're going to change the side
left hand to the front pull it with your
right five
four
three
two and one
bring it back
pull your elbow down five
four
three
two
and one
regret uh interlace your hands pull your
palms down straight your triceps
after some push-ups
that's that feels good
three
two and one hands down to the floor
three two one and last time cut your
breath in
keep it in inhale and bring your hands
down that's it good job guys well done
done thank you so much marco for that
kick-ass workout session
i hope all of you at home has enjoyed
the workout let us know in the comments
below how you felt if you're sweaty like
us give this video a thumbs up be sure
to share this video with your workout
buddy and don't forget to also hit the
subscribe button if you enjoyed
if you want another workout session with
marco then let us know in the comment
section below thank you so much marco
and
we'll see you in the next workout
session
all the best